good afternoon
it thank you thank you
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our back bench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now and the
timetable will be announced next week
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
so i want to say to the millions of
people who voted for us in 2019 many of
them voting conservative for the first
time
thank you
for that incredible mandate the biggest
conservative majority since 1987
the biggest share of the vote
since
1979
and the reason i have fought so hard in
the last few days to continue to deliver
that mandate in person
was not just because i wanted to do so
but because i felt it was
my job
my duty
my obligation to you to continue to do
what we promised in 2019
and of course i'm immensely proud of the
achievements of this government from
getting brexit done to settling our
relations
with the continent for over half a
century
reclaiming
the power for this country to make its
own laws in parliament getting us all
through the pandemic delivering the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe the
fastest exit from lockdown
and
in the last few months
leading the west in standing up to
putin's aggression in ukraine
and let me say now to the people of
ukraine that i know that we in the uk
will continue to back your fight for
freedom
for as long as it takes
and
at the same time in this country we've
been pushing forward a vast program of
investment in infrastructure and skills
and technology the biggest
in a century
because if i have one insight into human
beings it is that genius and talent and
enthusiasm and imagination
are evenly distributed throughout the
population but opportunity is not and
that's why we must keep leveling up keep
unleashing the potential of every part
of the united kingdom
and if we
can do that in this country we will be
the most prosperous in europe
and in the last few days i've tried to
persuade my colleagues that it would be
eccentric to change governments when
we're delivering so much and when we
have such a vast mandate and when we're
actually only a handful of points behind
in the polls even in mid-term after
quite a few months of pretty relentless
sledging and when
the economic scene is so difficult
domestically and internationally and i
regret and not to have been successful
in those arguments and of course it's
painful and not to be able to see
through so many ideas and projects
myself but as we've seen
at westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves and my friends in
politics no one is remotely
indispensable and our brilliant and
darwinian system will produce another
leader
equally committed to taking this country
forward through tough times
not just helping families to get through
it but changing and improving the way we
do things cutting burdens on businesses
and families and yes cutting taxes
because that is the way to generate the
growth and the income we need to pay for
great public services
and to that new leader i say whoever he
or she may be i say i will give you as
much support as i can
and to you
the british public
i know that there will be many people
who are relieved
and uh perhaps quite a few who will also
be disappointed
and i want you to know how sad i am
to be giving up
the best job in the world
but them's the brakes
i want to thank carrie and our children
and all the members of my family who
have had to put up with so much for so
long
i want to thank the peerless british
civil service for all the help and
support that you have given our police
our emergency services and of course
our
fantastic nhs who at critical moment
helped to extend my own period in office
as well as our armed services and our
agencies that are so admired around the
world
and are interfaciable conservative party
members and supporters whose selfless
campaigning makes our democracy possible
i want to thank the wonderful staff here
at checkers uh to here at number 10 and
of course at checkers and our fantastic
prop force detectives
the one group by the way
who never leak
above all
i want to thank
you the british public
for the immense privilege that you
have given me
and i want you to know
that from now on until the new prime
minister is in place
your interests
will be served
and the government of the country
will be carried on
being prime minister
is an education in itself
i've traveled to every part of the
united kingdom
and in addition to the beauty of our
natural world
i've found so many people
possessed
of such boundless british originality
and so willing to tackle old problems in
new ways
that i know that even if things can
sometimes
seem dark now
our future together
is golden
thank you all very much
thank you